TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show."
This is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
And this week, we have just
two quick cloud updates.
We've made some
recent contributions
to the open source projects
for Minikube, which
lets you run Kubernetes
workloads locally,
and Scaffold, a command line
tool for continuous development
on Kubernetes.
Now, these updates should
help speed up the workflow
and reduce the difference
between how we develop
and run locally versus
in a Kubernetes cluster.
And a lot more detail
is on the post.
A short while ago, we
announced a new user interface
for BigQuery to make it easier
to uncover insights and share
them with teammates
and colleagues.
This post highlights some
of the major improvements
that we've made to that
interface in the past five
months.
Some of the functionality was
available in the classic UI,
and some is totally new.
Click through for screenshots
and links to get started.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
It's actually my "Matrix" turn.
It's Keanu.